morphogen is a diffusable biochemical
molecule that can determine the fate of
the cell with the help of its
concentration and how it's
interpreted so morphogen is secreted by
the source cell and interpreted by the
responder cells obviously the cells
which are close to the morphogen source
would experience more uh morphogens than
the cells which are far apart and based
on that there could be different fate
choices moral of the story morphogen
gradient plays an important role in fet
specification several aspect of
morphogen gradient is interpreted there
could be tissue specific competence
morphogen Dynamics signaling Dynamics
and transcription Factor module which
all account to the Sate
specification now there are antagonist
and Agonist that interplay to stabilize
a morphogen gradient watch the full
video to know more